so do you think men should get a choice
on whether or not they should be a
father in the name of like equality
that's a difficult question
question it's not really it's really not
a difficult question i think in the sake
of
it
here's the thing
let's just all go back to sex know who
you're having sex with for one
and two stop stop nutting in people and
saying oh like oh like
that's just science that is science you
know you already know it's the same
thing with women like stop letting these
guys not in you yeah you get the you get
the final you're we're in control of sex
yes
i think both people are if it's
consensual sex then we're both having
men will never be able to have sex if a
woman says no otherwise it's called
grape that's that's the final say you
have the fight it goes both ways
but it still happens rather it's
not
if it happens both ways then why do men
when men come to the court and be like
yeah i got grapes here nothing's been
done about it by women because
everyone's because then women will look
at the other man
being a [ __ ] why are you acting like
that
i know they don't work like that i think
that's terrible that happens but i feel
like it should go both ways it should
consent to be mutual so then so do you
think then in the name of equality again
so it's equal both people should get the
choice of whether or not they get to be
parents so if at the point the baby's
conceived right the dad can either say
yes i want to be a parent or no i don't
want to be a parent the same way women
get to just start having sex contracts
at that point no no i'm not thinking
about that
would you say that would you say no
so okay can you repeat the question
honestly okay so women get the choice of
whether or not they want to be a mother
yeah so they get to say yes i'm carrying
this determiner no okay can men get the
choice of whether or not they they can
be a father so they can sign off
financial rights yet like before it's
born
i don't know
i think i think it's the case and i'm
only saying that is because it's like
who who am i to say that but then again
i honestly think it takes two to tango
like it's not just right it's not so
then shouldn't they both get a say
yes but you're having to say that's why
that's why i made a joke like okay let's
just have a sex contract at this point
because if you're both going into sex
knowing and this is a consensual thing
because i'm i'm not talking about grape
i'm talking about consensual sex but
both parties are are saying yes we want
to have sex so they're both equally
participating you can't just look at one
and say oh it's you osu no babies both
of us because we we both decided to lay
here knowing what could come but you're
moving i'm just asking you a question
yes or no yeah so i'm just saying like
like the the root along
the law is not going to be case to case
so i'm asking like yes or no we could
can men
get the same right to not be a parent as
women then i would say no no no because
look
put the put the shirt on the other foot
right let's say the woman wants to have
the kid right and the guy doesn't want
to but they they have it anyways right
and the kid the woman at the end
keeps the kid right and the kid is born
and everything like that the now the
father has to pay childs let's say they
don't want to he doesn't want it and he
wants to he wants he has to now by law
that's been instead by the country and
the world has to pay for that child
till he's 18. right right how is that
how how does that you know i didn't
ejaculate in myself well yeah yeah but
that's when you get women trying to trap
men like drake i think
and stuff because that that is that is
not even sex because they had consensual
sex and after
after that she went in the garbage
to retrieve
it yeah this girl that uh drake has sex
with she took the condom out but he has
a saying where he puts hot sauce in the
condom so she like tried to see there's
entire reddit threads from women talking
about how they're trying to trap their
boyfriend
i think that is
because that is not that's not happening
during sex that is after sex if you're
saying that you are taking a condom
after i've discarded it so that means
like the interaction has ended but i'm
also talking about women that tell their
boyfriends that they have an iud or
something
that's 99.99 effective and they don't so
what i'm saying is like now women have
all the rights and men have no say
so like like it's just interesting
because like where's the equality so i
would actually argue i think we already
see that there are a lot of guys who lit
who who not legally but they basically
tick that box and say i don't want to be
involved in this kid life so i'm not bi
i would say it takes two to tango right
for sure it does take two to tango
however i would say if you don't want to
have if you don't want to be in your
kid's life
tell me that say if i say if we say if
we get pregnant okay and i choose to
keep the child you don't want to have
the kid and you're like i don't want to
be in his life great tell me that now
you'll never have visitation rights you
won't have any of that if you don't want
to be a father fine but you don't get to
have any of the privileges of being a
father that's fine by me so huge support
but you're like one in a million saying
that though because a lot of the girls
still have a lot of the girls still try
you know
to basically no no not trapped in such a
way
like i see i think if we break down what
consensual sex is yeah i think that just
needs to like take place because it's
there's no way there's no way if if
we're talking about responsibility
there's no way that we can keep missing
the mark of
two people a male and a female having
sex could end in a baby like it's just
so if you know this and then your whole
point is like you know that this can
happen right then is everyone like
you can't look at just me and i can't
look at just you like we both are going
into the situation knowing what could
come right and so that's but it's
interesting because i bring this up
later like i bring up the men and
everyone's response is oh well you you
stuck your in it right no no not exactly
i mean i said that like but
like guys
but earlier when i was talking and i
said okay well why don't you like and
i'm saying as a woman like you should be
selective in who you're sleeping with
and you should know this type of stuff
like everyone's first response was oh
but she could be from a poor area oh but
she doesn't know like like men and women
have such a double standard i said no
from the jump when you asked that
question i said no from the guy i still
think it's quite complex like i wouldn't
know what to answer this question no i'm
just it's an observation when i was
talking to you like now right about
men um
like like
get signing away their rights right and
having that choice like the the
immediate response is well you should
know who you're like sleeping with da da
da da right and earlier when i say women
like they they should be selected they
should know who they're sleeping with
saying the same thing that you guys were
saying about men the immediate response
is oh well she could be poor she could
be have from a low-income household she
could be this she could be that like
it's like we always make excuses for
women but never for men we agree on that
point in regards to what you just
observed but like um when it came down
when it comes down to it in my opinion i
feel like um
both know that if having sex unprotected
obviously will lead to consequences of
getting pregnant but at the end of the
day i still regardless of what who has
what say the woman still has the choice
of whether or not she wants to have the
kids
and he should know that's a consequence
right yeah would you i can't remember
did you say you would support men being
able to sign up
i mean it depends if it's something
along what um
well damn ej aj said 100 was it
different than what i said because you
said sounded like what i said i think he
said that if he didn't want
explain what he said yeah so so i said
if you don't want to have a child with
me i feel pregnant and i have that child
then
be upfront about that but you don't get
any rights as a
you won't be in that child's life at all
so that's that's what i was saying so if
he says that like let's say three months
in right she says i'm having the kid he
says i don't want you to have it i want
you to get an abortion she says no he
can sign away all financial rights so he
he will never be liable for child
support he'll never have any rights to
the kids he can sign off his everything
to be a father you'd support that yeah
because i think then that's your that's
your decision as a woman then to go okay
knowing this do i still want to have
this child is it still actually
financially via like can i financially
do my position at the moment right okay
if i felt pregnant today i'm not enough
i'm not financially stable i'm not in a
stable relationship like i'm single
i would
never bring a child
into that right now because so i i grew
up working class okay
and i
think that the the so like when you were
talking earlier about you know you're
saying that poor women shouldn't have uh
i should shouldn't have the kids or like
them having access to the to an abortion
i was i was saying that that
um
what i was saying earlier was that
like the way you guys were talking it
sounded like poor people should be
aborted because of their financial
so it's absolutely not like they're
going to be able to because they're poor
they're absolutely not less valuable but
it's the fact that poor people are
actually no just literally viewed as
less valuable
within our society
uh look at the way we cannot be
completely shut on by the tories like
they don't care at all and we see that
in the way that they're
they're very very happy for the people
accessing food banks rising year on year
on year in the past 10 years of their
their rule so we see that like i
physically right now i wouldn't be able
to financially support a child okay so
for me it's not an option like
financially it's not an option to have a
child even though like i want to have
kids right i do want to have kids right
but i know what i want to bring that
child into and so for me it's like okay
if i had everything there if i had that
relationship
um then for me it's a case of well now
it's the fact that i'm in poverty that i
can't have this child to me that just
speaks volumes about the fact that
there's not enough support for people
who are poor to have these children
because otherwise you wouldn't have
people who are in poverty going i i need
to have this abortion because i can't
financially but support it but i would
have it if that wasn't the case that to
me is the sadness like that is a really
really sad
fact but it's a fact that is that is a
fact of the way our world works and so
that is a really big case why for me i
think if you are like for me that that's
a really big reason why i don't care
what your reasons are for you having an
abortion and i don't care if it's a case
of if you're poor because i understand
that i know that right that's my truth
too
[Music]
so i empathize with that and for me it's
not a case of poor people shouldn't have
kids it's not a case of like that's what
it would be either
that's what it would be
yeah
that's what it would be
no but it but it's just a fact it's just
the fact that like i can't support that
child myself and then in that situation
you go okay well you could put them up
for foster care you could have them put
into adoption i will say that a lot of
my friends i grew up in a very poor
quite poor town
and a lot of my friends grew up below
the poverty line i'm talking on like
their family surviving on a pound a day
very very like the lowest of abject
poverty i knew a lot of people who were
in the foster system who were in the
care system and they were abused their
entire time through it they had an awful
time loads of those friends became drug
addicts or died
quite a few of my friends and it's
really it's horrible and it's a horrible
thing to see but you go
i don't i would not want to have a kid
and that be their eventuality and the
same if you've got a mother who's a drug
addict right but there's also any other
but that's just how you like that's like
your world view is that if people are
into it go into adoption or foster care
it's an automatically a negative
experience no it's not but this is this
is what can i can i finish how can i
finish so so this is what i'm saying
like like there's kids that come out of
that and they get into really good
situations like that
that's a lot of luck i think that's very
rare what evidence do you have that it's
rare well in the uk i can only speak for
the uk but if you're in foster care the
experience isn't like oh it was great
and like it's never like i know i'm
talking about i just i'm sure
i'm sure we could pull up a statistic
for this and i would be happy to find it
now yeah
institutionalized children are more
likely to commit crime that's in
psychology studies based on that and
people that commit command normally have
not a good home life
you can infer that so i do think in the
uk
if you're institutionalized or bought
for adoption and put it for foster care
yeah your quality of life isn't the same
as that of if you're living in youtube
you're more likely to experience abuse
sexual violence in the home you're more
likely to be poor you're more likely to
commit crime right so they shouldn't
exist no no no
it's about it all goes down to resources
right it blows down the resources no
one's saying that oh [ __ ] you you're
poor right is this not
even poor people today are richer than
people have been in all of human history
and they didn't do that my point is
actually the opposite my point is that
poor people should be able to have
children and it's awful that people are
in the position
where they cannot and so because they
are lacking the resources which is why
i'm tying it together
it all ties to resources no one is
saying oh we don't care about poor
people i think there are more poor
people in the world there is only two
percent of people in the world are
actually rich
there's less there are more poor people
but you realize but you realize today
even a poor person is rich by in the in
all of human history doesn't matter if
you look yes it does yes but people say
if you're
looking at it on a history on a history
standpoint saying that more people are
richer and poorer
no if i if i am if you're going to if
i'm if i'm in the consideration
okay one increasing what if you're gonna
say that you're gonna have to take into
consideration how each um inflation
inflation interest rates whatever you
want to say is increasing value of life
is value of life value of um living
is becoming ridiculously expensive so
even though
even though the poor people would be
historically much better now than ever
right it's still not at the point where
you can say okay cool that means they're
better off do you know what i mean i
don't actually know if we are better off
though because actually there are way
more people now in debt than there ever
was yeah and so
if you're saying like that obviously the
money that we have today is not the same
as it will as it would weigh back in
like
in past times so saying this is like oh
yeah the poor people are are richer than
they've ever been if i am five pounds in
debt or ten pounds in debt i'm still in
debt and it's obviously not on a five
pound it's not a fiver that you're gonna
be in debt you're gonna be in debt
thousands and thousands so like saying
oh i i'm out of a hundred thousand i'm
out of ten thousand you're still out of
thousands like right but but what i'm
saying is is that like in in human
history most people don't have air
conditioning most people have tvs even
even some people in the us that qualify
for financial
aid have tvs they have air conditioning
they have things that like people never
had in all of history so all of history
but like what does it matter what
happened yesterday
like
i mean it says that you have disposable
income if you can buy a tv i don't even
have a tv
like history can affect
no it's i'm saying like they didn't need
abortions like people didn't do
abortions as much as they do now back
that